i almost died yeah and i didn't know
this for people that don't know i almost
died i was in the hospital in denver and
i was there for three and a half weeks
and there's people that have quadruple
bypass surgeries that are in and out in
four days
and i there for three and a half weeks
and the doctor told me i had a 10 chance
of living
and then when i got out and i got better
they had lied to me i was supposed to be
dead so my family flew in to say goodbye
to me no and they told me that you have
a 10 chance and then my sister was like
yeah they lied that you were gonna you
were supposed to die
so that's a trip dude when you
experience something like that and then
you come back to life essentially
it just changes your whole
[ __ ] st
mindset dude because you're just like oh
i'm like now living on borrowed time
that's how i see it so how long once
that hap because what you got taken were
you at a place and collapsed did
something like what was what happened i
flew into denver i got sick in my hotel
minneapolis
and then i was like whatever i'm used to
that i was throwing up like bile then i
got on the plane drank on the plane
threw up into my carry-on
so then i got off the plane i'm like
[ __ ]
so then i hadn't eaten or anything so i
ate like you've been were you drinking
i just kept drinking but i kept vomiting
and it was more and more painful than i
had
a pain in my stomach but i had a pain
that was different it was like pain like
fire pain yeah and i kept trying to
drink through it
and then i'm like oh this no something's
horribly wrong
and i went
to the medic at the airport and they're
like oh you need an ambulance at the
airport well yeah they have like
somebody you know what i mean i'm like
hey something's wrong wait was it that
express spa or whatever that uh
it wasn't like a massage chair i didn't
sit there and like
no i
grabbed a human
okay at a ticket counter i'm like hey i
something's wrong and the guy looked at
me and he goes oh you need an ambulance
they call me an ambulance and i went to
the [ __ ] you got ambulance out of the
airport
yeah where does it pick up at departures
or arrivals
i don't remember but i think i i i think
it was departures because they thought i
was going to have it oh
jesus was my pilot he was like
and did you have a beer at the airport
i was drinking vodka and i just kept
going and throwing it up and i'm like
okay this is i can't get through this i
drank a gatorade threw it up i had a
like a banana sometimes you were puking
up bile
what's after bile
um
more bile
and then blood yeah and then blood so
then then it was blood at the hospital
it was [ __ ] gnarly dude
it was like it was
i'll never forget then i i don't even
remember a whole week they were telling
me about what i was doing
and the nurse was like yeah you're like
throwing haymakers trying to like
you're watching wrestling on your
computer
yeah it was crazy but there's pictures
of it there's pictures of me with like
they had to like put mittens on my hands
you wouldn't drink yeah no so i wouldn't
pull the ivs out and really yeah it was
[ __ ] bonkers so you were you went i
mean you went crazy yeah essentially
like i totally lost my [ __ ] yeah and the
altitude was a big factor in that what
[ __ ] no
like you tell these crazy stories like i
drank 70 drinks i [ __ ]
yeah you're like but there were some
raiders fans there and that's kind of
the thing that made things strange man
yeah no i drank a gallon of house paint
but you know
there was a drizzle
there was a drizzle outside yeah it was
yeah it was a cloud it was cloudy but
yeah i didn't plan on like that
happening so but do you think you could
because you could if you because you
probably i mean at that point you get
cirrhosis bad things happen to your body
yeah i mean i came really close but i
didn't i mean i'm fine now i mean
obviously like
did they say you can drink again or you
can't drink again
well it was the doctor goes if you have
another drink you're gonna die so i was
like well that doesn't make sense
but i'm like okay so then i i rehabbed
and then got you know better and i got
really healthy and then i went and got a
check up three months after and the
doctor was like oh yeah a different
doctor back in l.a and he's like yeah
you're fine everything's fine and i'm
like what and he goes yeah it's all yeah
everything's back your liver's back i
mean i was like really you're living
hard well your liver can
rebound yeah i mean you can get to a
point where it can't where i've had a
handful of friends where that's happened
to
but i mean you can push it and then
you've got to really dry out so i did it
with vitamins and [ __ ] milk thistle
everything just built back up
and then i still wait another six months
and then covet hit and quarantine i went
to key west
and i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna it doesn't make sense so i had a
cocktail and i was i was fine and then i
drank again
yeah i just want you to be which sounds
dumb i'm sure people are like you're a
[ __ ] idiot but i didn't drink like i
was drinking very rogue i mean i was
just boom shots and just completely
stupid wow but now i'll like you know i
can have a cocktail i can do stuff like
that but you do have to be
really careful do you think you can have
a cocktail yeah i did i told you i had
like a cocktail when i wrapped this
movie buddy games part two hard r
yeah so we celebrated and i had a
cocktail and it was fine
so yeah it is interesting you know with
the levels of
you know what people can do because some
people can't they have one drink and
then they wake up in a [ __ ] prison
and i know but that sounds
most your stories sound like that you
know i know
but i'm i don't know somehow i've made
it knocked out
oh you're a [ __ ] yeah i mean you're
you're like
yeah you're like the ghost of
fuddrucker's past
i am dude you keep going the ghost of
future chili's
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one